every year competition is held to find
the best Assamese dish in the region and
it's happening here today 40 cooks
battle out for the title
I'm going to enter but in order to rub
shoulders with the best cooks in a Sam I
need a winning recipe serve wrangled and
in with a local domestic goddess at all
suggested that I spent some time with
his missus she's gonna show me exactly
how she cooks if there's one way of
going back to Calcutta with some really
exciting stunning dishes it's going to
be from this competition
finally this is a first for me entering
a domestic competition actually today
I'm going to show you how to cook
chicken with sis missing
chicken with sesame seed yes and who
taught you this dish I just learned it
from my mother my granny I I always do
my cooking at home because I told he
doesn't like to cook at home he is
better in his restaurant he's like me
why why well I haven't got the staff at
home get that noise the mustard oil
oh yes it's nice yeah we never use
refine our what we prefer is the mustard
oil right that's the flavor yeah we do
for less on I feel like I'm back at
school with my home economic gotcha
yeah yeah
young and sexy onions garlic you should
be put in whole yeah yeah oh the chicken
in it's quite dry but
that's what very slim and beautiful
manner boy from a yoga Rashmi's healthy
family recipe then uses fresh turmeric
and coriander the color has to remain
green so it's a green curry Jesus this
is a housewife competition you'll say
seriously so straight it will remain
green yeah promise yeah that smells
delicious curry looks amazing
yes I don't recognize the final
ingredient it's black sesame seed paste
and it's only used in North East Indian
curries okay good very tempting isn't it
is very tempting
it looks fantastic yeah are you hungry
I am a little bit I don't like to eat
before I go into competitions nervous
energy yes yes lovers you don't want to
eat I'll have a little taste
yes very good everything is perfect yeah
everything I'm not gonna say darling
will say chef thank you thank you that
delicious fingers crossed
I think attles missus might actually be
a better cook than he is so this is a
token of love for me and just you're
going to bring it it's a good luck okay
Cheetos particular change it turned up a
sesame seed paste at the end at the end
hello Jesus the best dish in our Sam is
a much sought-after title yes I'm here
too yeah I'm here to cook oliver's Thank
You ash indeed you may see my 40 fellow
competitors have been perfecting the
recipes for months but I want to give
them a run for their money
Ready Steady boost are [ __ ]
I'm feeling pretty confident I just need
to remember what goes in first
[Music]
it'll smell darling this one not too
much garlic no okay good
all right lid on keep it like that for
you please yeah
and just turn down the gas a little bit
and have a little wonder while that
reduces I'm sneaking up to spy on the
competition
[Music]
and this one is vision that smells nice
now what's this one here opium poppy
seeds poppy seeds and this is chicken
all I'm doing chicken as well well sir
you got in there onions garlic do a
little bit of decoration aren't they is
that for your decoration Wow
okay right I'll get my Austin to you and
do some decoration this lot might look
like Indians answer to the WI but
they're actually pretty good cooks there
now garnishing their dishes is gone up a
notch bloody how they started out as a
sort of domestic sort of yeah local
competition they know what they're doing
crafty buggers well two can play that
game have done more these ins as a
college a little van Dijk of tomato
fifteen minutes left yes thank you thank
you Ainsley Honda in please come out the
same colors machine I've got to stay
green okay yeah observing so much in the
che know my life you know the judges
will be grateful excellent thank you
thank you very much other than
congratulations what was the dish
chicken exam Oh what did she do to the
chicken that I didn't do and papaya with
chicken yeah pressure cooker
I love you all thank you I don't like
coming second best okay make sure I'm
going back oh yes I think number one
thank you
papaya a chicken that sounds interesting
that isn't it yeah and I mean okay
didn't win fine but what I did come here
for was to pick up some knowledge to see
how I can put that in to the streets of
Calcutta thank you ladies thank us
indeed good bye now